Do you mention herbs or meopathy for nausea?
If I prescribe nausea meds with my chemo,
should I get these other options to try first?
I think it's always good to try non-medications
before trying medications.
You have to be honest
and say that lots of times medications are going to work better,
but they're not without side effects.
I don't think anybody can argue that pain meds
can do a great job of taking care of pain,
can get rid of my pain.
Probably better than anything else,
especially if I got serious pain,
but it also comes with side effects.
You always try to do things as natural as possible
for all sorts of reasons.
So I would definitely try that first,
but I would go ahead and take the prescription,
so you have it,
and if you have to use it, you have to use it,
but using some of the herbs and meopathy
for some symptoms can be helpful.
The ones for nausea can be helpful.
But I mean people that are other anti-dose medication
over the years, and they're still in horrible nausea,
and they use both.
So everybody's a little bit different that way.